[Música]
desde muy pequeña he tenido la
convicción de que la vida nos presenta
momentos que nos guían para poder
encontrar el propósito de nuestra
existencia pero hace poco logré entender
que muchas veces es por medio del dolor
como encontramos nuestro motor de vida
en mi caso cáncer una palabra corta pero
devastadora y lo más curioso es que no
fue mi dolor lo que me lleva a tomar
acción fue ver el sufrimiento de tantos
niños que a diario son diagnosticados y
de las 720 familias que hoy escucharán
las palabras lo sentimos su hijo tiene
cáncer lo que muchos ignoran es que el
cáncer es la principal causa de muerte
por enfermedad en niños a nivel mundial
hoy 274 niños morirán a causa del cáncer
pero la gente nunca lo sabrá porque no
es algo que se vean las noticias son
niños que perdieron su vida por una
enfermedad que consumió sus pequeños
cuerpos muchos mueren por la falta de
atención y por las extremas condiciones
de pobreza y vulnerabilidad
triste no es verdad lo más triste es que
seamos conscientes de esta realidad y no
hagamos nada para cambiarlo pero ahora
la verdadera pregunta es qué hacemos con
ese dolor cómo convertir ese dolor en
una oportunidad de vivir mejor para que
cada niño sepa que esta vida es mucho
más que solo su enfermedad que hay
esperanza hay una infinidad de momentos
maravillosos por vivir aún estando en
esta lucha hace poco conocí la historia
de una joven de 21 años con fibrosis
quística su nombre era clair y su vida
estuvo llena de grandes logros todo
comenzó con cambiar su perspectiva dejar
de sentir lástima por su vida y su
enfermedad y utilizar ese sufrimiento
para hacer de su vida la más grande
aventura pero hacer este cambio también
depende de nosotros depende de la
alegría que seamos capaces de
transmitirles a estos pequeños para que
cada día su lucha se convierta en una
nueva oportunidad para ser felices hoy
quiero compartir con ustedes la historia
de un niño colombiano que ha luchado
durante toda su vida a los 18 meses fue
diagnosticado con un cáncer muy agresivo
llamado rabdomiosarcoma pasó por muchas
rondas de quimioterapia y radiación
hasta ser declarado libre de enfermedad
pero unos años más tarde se encontró
frente a una batalla mucho más grande
esta vez contra un cáncer secundario que
surgió por efecto de la radiación que
recibió a causa de este nuevo
diagnóstico este pequeño perdió su
pierna y hoy 11 años después sigue en
esta lucha
su nombre es matías y esta es su
historia hoy años hay un matías y tengo
10 años y quiero decir una historia o mi
historia
matilla fue diagnosticado con un cáncer
desde los 18 meses en mi rodilla no era
muy venenosa había nada hecho después
como mi pierna no creció por la
radiación que me hicieron a mi pierna
para quitar
el cáncer me tuvieron que poner un tutor
y tornillos para creer que crezca mi
pierna y después de eso me rompí la
pierna jugando fútbol del mundo a sus
pacientes para
esta es la mejor
caminar y después podría crear otro
cáncer ahí entonces decidimos quitar la
pierna
matías es un niño con una energía
impresionante con un carisma también muy
muy lindo después me salió un cáncer en
mi boca ya esto era mi boca no podía ni
comer pero tuvieron que quitar o sí no
moría y casi muero pero teniendo quiero
ser una zona
siento
que yo puedo hacer más que estar en la
tierra
toca avanzar
cuando yo ahora a veces que a veces
con fuerza
así como matías hay cientos de historias
que a diario me impulsan a seguir pero
fue una experiencia en especial la que
me mostró esta realidad cuando yo tenía
12 años tuve que ir a la clínica por una
gastroenteritis y mientras estaba ya
entró una niña vomitando sangre yo
estaba muy impactada pero nunca me
imaginé que ese día vería cara a cara el
dolor más grande que cualquier padre
puede experimentar a los pocos minutos
la niña había fallecido por una leucemia
tenía 12 años y su nombre era camila
ella fue quien me mostró esta realidad y
poco a poco fui acercándome a las
historias de otros pequeños que luchan
contra esta enfermedad en todo el mundo
en ese momento encontré el propósito de
mi vida pero con él también llegaron
miedos que me hicieron dudar de lo que
podía lograr yo pensaba que nadie me iba
escuchar o apoyar por mi corta edad y
deje que todos esos pensamientos me
impidieron comenzar pero en el 2016
cuando tenía 15 años conocí las
historias de otros dos pequeños
brooks de seis años y más
ellos me mostraron la necesidad de estas
familias de tener a alguien que lucha a
su lado y los acompañe en este camino
así que gracias a ellos decidí correr el
riesgo e intentar hacer algo para
cambiar la realidad de estos pequeños y
sus familias así ignacio momentos de
esperanza y desde entonces mi propósito
ha sido darles motivos para sonreír y
ser felices a pesar del dolor y la
enfermedad durante estos tres años este
camino me ha llevado a alcanzar lo
inimaginable y me ha permitido conocer
personas maravillosas que cada día me
reafirman que ésta ha sido la decisión
más valiosa que he tomado en mi vida
todo comenzó con una página de instagram
y un solo propósito dar a conocer las
historias de todos estos pequeños que
luchan contra esta enfermedad en todo el
mundo pero unos meses más tarde me di
cuenta de las muchas necesidades
económicas y materiales de estas
familias y tomé la decisión de hacer
algo más
así es como con la ayuda de
patrocinadores se han logrado enviar y
entregar más de 750 paquetes a niños de
colombia otros países de suramérica
canadá
a eeuu y el reino unido- cada uno de
éstos lleno de juguetes personalizados
según los gustos del niño y en muchas
ocasiones artículos que puedan
satisfacer algunas de sus necesidades
para hacer de las estadías en el
hospital unas más agradables y con esto
logramos llegar a sus vidas para darles
momentos de felicidad que pueda sembrar
en ellos esperanza y la certeza de que
esta vida y este camino puede hacerse
más llevadero
en el 2018 llegó a mi vida una niña que
cambió mi forma de ver el mundo una
pequeña que me hizo creer en lo que era
capaz de lograr y me impulsó a intentar
cosas nuevas y más grandes su nombre era
valeria y en sus cortos cinco años de
vida logró impactar infinitos corazones
el día que la conocí me cautivó su
sonrisa y sus ganas de vivir pero ese
día también me di cuenta que esta
pequeña tenía el tiempo limitado pues
hace muchos años se encontraba luchando
contra un cáncer muy agresivo que
amenazaba con quitarle la vida
esa noche sus padres me dijeron que vale
tenía el deseo de conocer el mar y antes
de irme me agaché y le dije yo no sé
cómo lo voy a hacer pero te prometo que
vas a conocer el mar en la noche no
dormí pensando en una manera de
conseguirme 5 millones de pesos para
hacer su sueño realidad pero gracias a
dios y al apoyo de muchísimas personas
en dos semanas todo el dinero estaba
reunido y vale pudo ir por cuatro días a
san andrés con su familia
tan solo un mes después de cumplir su
sueño
valeria dejó nuestro lado y partió al
cielo no sin antes dejar un legado de
infinito amor que mueve muchísimos
corazones y me ha inspirado a hacer
otros sueños realidad es increíble ver
la felicidad de un niño al experimentar
algo por primera vez al visitar un lugar
que siempre ha soñado
alegría y ese asombro le dan una
fortaleza inimaginable a sus padres
momentos maravillosos para recordar
gracias a cada uno de estos pequeños he
aprendido que la vida es el regalo más
preciado que tenemos pero que depende de
nosotros vivirla bien hace algunos meses
leí una frase que me gustó mucho y decía
morir es inevitable pero vivir una vida
de la que nos sintamos orgullosos eso es
algo que podemos controlar alrededor del
mundo hay muchísimas personas que sin
importar su edad procedencia o los
medios que tenían para comenzar
decidieron enfrentar cada obstáculo para
lograr construir eso que siempre soñaron
hoy quiero que conozcan algunos de ellos
analí swan una niña de 12 años
apasionada por la moda a los 7 años
comenzó a diseñar y actualmente tiene un
estudio de alta costura en bali
indonesia donde son los mismos
habitantes de la zona quienes hacen cada
prenda a mano pero aquí no ha parado la
labor de hannah pues ha encontrado una
manera de dar desde su labor dona un don
de informes para muchas escuelas en la
india
lily baby y a darle y manrique dos
hermanos caleños que crecieron en la
comuna 20 y a pesar de las muchas
dificultades lograron convertirse en
excelentes docentes de inglés años más
tarde vuelven a su comunidad para darle
la misma oportunidad a otros niños y
niñas creando así el primer colegio
bilingüe de siloé greta una joven sueca
de 16 años que a pesar de su diagnóstico
de autismo se ha logrado convertir en
una de las líderes ambientalistas más
influyentes de este siglo para mí ellos
son el mejor ejemplo que ni la edad ni
el dinero son impedimentos para alcanzar
eso que siempre hemos querido lograr y
que está en todos el poder de crear una
diferencia en la vida de cada persona
que sufre en el mundo
hace algunos meses estos niños tenían
vidas normales y sus familias días
cotidianos pero un día el cáncer lo
cambió todo así que por qué esperar a
que sea tu hija tu sobrina o tu nieta
para tomar acción unamos nuestras voces
para darle una a nuestros niños y así
lograremos un cambio inimaginable por
eso hoy espero que nos demos cuenta que
estos pequeños no necesitan y que es una
cura por la que vale la pena luchar
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]